john f kennedy school of government and
practice law
in washington d.c and new york he
received his ba
from columbia university and his law
degree
from nyu school of law and i'll now turn
it over to senator blunt to introduce
the
two other witnesses uh thank you senator
klobuchar since you
responded to senator mcconnell's
comments i have just one brief comment
to what senator schumer say he said he'd
like for any republican
to answer the question of why georgia
should eliminate voting on sunday
they are not eliminating voting on
sunday it did not pass the legislature
the republican governor even
the republican lieutenant governor even
refused to
preside over the debate this is an idea
like most of the 253 ideas out there
introduced by some republican in some
legislatures somewhere
that will not happen we can spend all
day
talking about legislation that was filed
by republicans that had that will not
become law
or we can talk about this bill and i
hope we get to where we talk about this
bill i have two witnesses today we've
asked
who can talk about this bill with great
knowledge of how this bill will affect
states
one of our witnesses todd rakita was
elected to
serve as the attorney general of indiana
in november of 2020.
prior to that todd rakita served indiana
in the congress
and as indiana's secretary of state todd
was elected as president of the national
association of secretaries of state
in 2007. our second witness today
mack warner is west virginia's 30th
secretary of state
he graduated from the united states
military academy at west point
and the west virginia university school
of law
prior to serving as secretary of state
he served his country for 23 years
in the united states army in five years
in afghanistan with the state department
and i'd like to turn to
senator capito for any additional
comments she might make about her
secretary of state
uh mack warner well thank you senator
thank all of you and i want to thank our
secretary of state mack warner for
joining us today he ran a flawless
election in 2020 under difficult
situations for everybody
our we had more people voting we had no
disputes uh to speak of
and i want to thank our secretary of
state for not only being a leader
in this area on mobile voting as well
but also for serving our country he
comes from a
long line of west virginians and i'm
proud to have him here with us today
thank you
very good we'll start with our first
witness
the witnesses have five minutes for an
opening
statement and we will begin with
attorney general holder
thank you chairman klobuchar ranking
member blunt
uh members of the committee i want to
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you today you know for as long as
this country has
existed there have been two opposing
forces that have fought over how we
define
and confer the rights and privileges of
citizenship freedom
and equality every step that has brought
us closer to universal suffrage has
has been met by those often by those who
are in power who want to maintain
an unjust status quo much in the same
way that reconstruction was followed by
the era of jim crow
the progress won by the civil rights
movement including the voting rights
act of 1965 has faced a multi-pronged
assault that has sought to take us back
to an era in which politicians not the
people
pick who wins and consequently who can
participate
in elections the events of the past few
months have brought into stark focus
what has been true
for too long there is a large and
powerful faction in this country
intent on retaining power and will bend
or break
the rules of our democracy in order to
do so the attack on our system of
government did not begin
or end with the insurrection of the
capital on january the 6th
for years now politicians have spread
the same lies about voter fraud
and advanced falsehoods about the
integrity of our electoral
system the fact is that there is no
evidence of widespread
or systemic fraud during the 2020
election
or at any other time yet state
legislators around the country have used
these
baseless assertions as a pretext to
introduce as you've heard more than 250
bills
in 43 states that would restrict who can
vote
this new wave of bills is the latest
step in a decade-long project to
systematically chip away or outright
eliminate key protections for voters in
a way that is undermined our
representative democracy
too many americans and particularly
people of color face discriminatory and
onerous barriers
to vote the for the people act is a
necessary
and appropriate response to both the
erosion of voting rights
and the advancement of special interests
the combination of unprecedented
partisan gerrymandering during the 2011
redistricting process
the wave of voter suppression bills
passed in the wake of the supreme
court's disastrous shelby county
decision
and the flood of dark money unleashed by
the court's citizens united decision
have all combined to create a political
system that does not adequately
represent
the desires of the american people the
for the people act is the
right remedy at the right time this bill
recognizes that the best solution to
abolishing the
undemocratic trinity of issues plaguing
our democracy
gerrymandering voter suppression dark
money
is to get rid of all of them at once by
creating a baseline of protection for
voters
rooting out corruption and dark money
and ending the practice of partisan
gerrymandering
this congress can create a fair level
playing field in our electoral
system this bill also makes evident that
congress should pass the john lewis
voting rights advancement act which
would update the formula for determining
which jurisdictions are subject to
federal free clearance
now take it together before the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
represent the greatest pieces of civil
rights legislation since 1965
and are badly needed reforms that will
strengthen our democracy
now despite what opponents may say this
bill would not favor
either party the contrary it would
create a level playing field
for the american people the reality is
that no matter what political party you
support
or what policies you advocate your voice
will be stronger if
politicians are required to be
responsive to your needs
now is the time for congress to exercise
its constitutional authority
to protect the structure of our
representative democracy
ensuring a true representative democracy
is how we advance equality
opportunity and justice in areas where
too many americans are still
let down left out and left behind
it's how we make every vote count
and how we make every voter count it's
making the determination of what kind of
country we want to be
one closer to its founding promise or a
nation turning away from our democratic
ideals passing this bill will be a
critical and necessary step to restoring
power
to the people where it belongs
thank you thank you very much
attorney general holder um next with
us today secretary andrew mack warner
from west virginia
thank you chairwoman klobuchar ranking
member blunt and members of this
committee
thank you for letting me address the
implications of s-1 on the state of west
virginia dubbed for the people's act
this is anything but for the people in
fact it is against the people
it is against the states and it is
against the united states
first it is against the people because
it overrules access
and it overrules checks and balances my
most vehement objection to this is by
prohibiting electronic transmission of
ballots
it strips the most efficient and secure
form of voting for our military
the people who put their very lives on
the line for our democracy and way of
life
when i was deployed as were my two sons
my two daughters my two sons in all all
of whom served in the u.s army
it has prohibited they have had
difficulty voting
therefore when i became secretary of
state i determined to fix this and we
did it through electronic transmission
of ballots
using mobile devices we proved the
technology with our military and
and then we extended it to voters with
disabilities
giving them not just the right to vote
but the opportunity to vote
31 states allow electronic transmission
and s-1 strips this opportunity
for everyone to vote electronically
how is this for the people clearly it's
not
s1 also overrules checks and balances in
our election security it mandates avr
including 60 16 year olds it bans id
laws and shields not its citizens
from prosecution it eliminates signature
verification it pushes mail-in voting
without photo id
it promotes ballot harvesting and
requires drop boxes
it delays election results by requiring
acceptance of ballots up to 10 days
that delay and all of these collectively
decrease
individual confidence and it increases
distrust
in our elections second s-1 is against
the states because it requires a huge
expansion of state legislation and
imposes funding mandates far beyond
states abilities to implement it forces
decertification of every voting machine
in west virginia
wasting tens of millions of dollars that
you've provided to us
through hava funding it mandates
same-day registration which requires
poll books
connected to the internet through
high-speed broadband something west
virginia
simply cannot do we do not have high
band uh or high-speed
broadband in all the precincts of west
virginia
it requires agencies beyond dmv such as
colleges and social services
to automatically register people that
come in contact with them
and transmit their personal
identification information
thereby increasing risks for hackers and
it busts
our budgets it forces election officials
to accept and count ballots voted in
incorrect precincts
it stops it stops states from cleaning
up voter registration lists
and west virginia's clerk association
president linda huggins said this
clerks are unanimously against s-1
because deadlines
cannot be met and requirement
requirements are not achievable
clerk michelle hawley cited unfunded
mandates as show
and clerk brian wood said it doesn't
matter if you're democrat or republican
if you want to keep our democracy intact
you've got to leave it up to states to
run their elections
to implement the changes by january 1st
a special session of our legislature
would be required
which is not practical and would be
hugely expensive in sum
take away the ideology and the
partisanship
clerks across west virginia most of whom
i'm told are democrats
are against s-1 third s-1
is a vast federal overreach this
800-page monstrosity
stomps on states rights the u.s
constitution does say that the time
place and manner of elections shall be
prescribed by state legislatures
states have individual approaches based
on history geography
and cultures that create vastly complex
and different election processes
this broad mosaic provides election
security
versus a one-size-fits-all approach the
private right of action remedy is
tremendously problematic
as are the number of severability
clauses that indicate
s-1 is not likely to withstand judicial
scrutiny
the court cases will increase delays
cause confusion and
distrust in our already contentious
intense election process
in conclusion s-1 is not for the people
especially not for the people of west
virginia federalizing elections has
never been done before and for good
reason
senators please leave election
administration
up to the states the impossible
requirements and unfunded mandates of
s-1
will create election chaos and further
divide our country
on behalf of the state of west virginia
as its chief elections official
i urge you to consider these grave
implications and i thank you for this
opportunity
to bring these various serious flaws and
concerns to your consent
consideration thank you thank you and
for a different perspective on the bill
the secretary of state for the state of
michigan
jocelyn benson
the election of 2020 is behind us the
war on democracy is escalating
and in addition to the ongoing efforts
of democracy deniers to spread
misinformation
alongside continued attacks and threats
against election officials a new
battlefront has emerged in state
legislatures all across the country
yet michigan's story demonstrates a
different path our experience
underscores that voters on both sides of
the aisle want reforms like those in the
for the people act
and it shows how with sufficient funding
partnerships
leadership and political will it is
entirely possible to efficiently and
successfully implement those reforms
in november 2018 michigan citizens voted
overwhelmingly to amend our state
constitution
to instill the right to vote absentee
without a reason
same-day voter registration automatic
voter registration
and an independent citizens
redistricting commission
my office was charged with working with
600 clerks all across our state to
implement all of these policies
in advance of the 2020 election cycle
and we did
because these policies are not new and
implementing them is not rocket science
and many states already have these
reforms in place we conferred with
leaders in those states to learn from
their experience replicate best
practices and modernize our democracy
effectively and efficiently
we implemented automatic voter
registration for example with security
protocols in place to ensure that only
eligible citizens were registered
by november 2020 we increased our number
of registered voters by a quarter of a
million
we found that voters on both sides of
the aisle embrace the ability to vote
absentee and use
secure drop boxes to return their
ballots the number of people voting
absentee in michigan increased
exponentially from 1.1 million in
november 2016
to 3.3 million in november 2020 and we
saw thousands of new voters register in
the days leading up to the november
election
including 30 000 on election day itself
and the majority of those were under 30.
in the end due in no small part to these
reforms
we had the most successful secure
election in our state's history
we've also succeeded in implementing
michigan's first independent citizens
redistricting commission
enacted by voters in 2018. we found that
when given the chance citizens embrace
the opportunity to draw their own
legislative districts
the commission is already at work and
you can learn more about their work at
redistricting michigan.org
now if michigan can do all of this in
one election cycle in the midst of a
global pandemic enduring one of the most
significant
and highly scrutinized election cycles
in our lifetime
every state in the country with proper
funding and leadership
can do the same because while states are
laboratories of our democracy
federal minimum standards ensure equal
protection of every citizen's right to
vote
and yes every state will face unique
circumstances
in incorporating a new federal floor but
it's our job to meet those challenges
not to jerk them just as the national
voter registration act took a popular
state policy in michigan the motor voter
law
and made it a nationwide convenience for
every citizen
it will take collaboration partnerships
leadership and funding
but it can be done truly only politics
and political will
stands in our way i want to close by
noting
that 56 years ago at this very moment
thousands were marching from montgomery
to montgomery alabama from selma to
similarly call on their federal
government to protect their
vote against the efforts of states to
impede their access
many of those brave advocates were
beaten some lost their lives
but their work led to the passage of the
voting rights one of the most effective
voters in our nation's history
when it was proposed it was met by many
of the same tax and critiques that we
could say
opponents said compliance would be
impossible that it would be an overreach
of federal authority
but in the years that followed those
critics were proved wrong
and our nation became a more perfect
union as a result
so clearly history instructs and the
current moment demands they once again
step in and defend democracy
at this moment you are our greatest hope
and this legislation is our best chance
to stop this rollback on voting rights
that is sweeping state legislatures
throughout the country
i urge you to act and advance this
legislation because no matter where a
voter lives
or who they vote for their right to vote
should be protected
the future of our democracy depends on
your leadership
today thank you
thank you very much secretary benson
the next witness is attorney general
todd rakita
thank you for being with us
uh thank you chairwoman ranking member
appreciate you inviting me to speak
today on behalf of the citizens of
indiana
uh my name is todd rakita and i serve as
the attorney general for the state of
indiana and prior to serving
as in the in part of that i served as
indiana's chief election officer
as well as a member of congress giving
my experience as indiana's chief
election officer
and in various offices i know how
elections can and should be run to
ensure transparency
and public confidence in i elections
we don't hear enough about the need for
public confidence
in our elections in order to make this
republic work
any effort to address america's election
system must begin with recognition of a
simple fact the
2020 presidential election was unlike
any other
in our history and it doesn't need to be
repeated
because we shouldn't be having pandemics
every time we have a presidential
election
the 2020 election involved an effort to
convert what has traditionally been
election day in our country to a
months-long process of vote gathering
ballot harvesting last minute rule and
law
changes by people not authorized to do
so and all this resulted in shaken
confidence in our electoral system and a
profound
unease if not outright distrust
about the results americans saw
mountains of mail-in ballots being
processed and cavernous central count
processing centers tens of millions of
mail-in ballots overloading
the processing capacity of the system in
many states
turning the tabulation of those into a
weeks-long process
and in any case after case we saw vote
watchers and observers excluded
from an opaque seemingly never-ending
counting process
many of the problems of 2020 resulted
from the efforts of those without the
authority to do so trying to control
how the election was run and changing
election rules
at the last minute this led to an
unprecedented number of election
lawsuits that frankly have overwhelmed
the system senate bill one
would increase the number of those
lawsuits
both against states and states suing the
federal government
the mandates of this bill are wholly
unnecessary and the determinations for
how elections are operated should remain
with the states
as intended by the framers for good
reason
the proposed changes will open our
elections up to increase voter fraud
and irregularities and promote perhaps
the most egregious provision
is the axe elimination of voter and
photo id
laws requiring government-issued photo
id at the polls represents a common
sense
simple best practice for election
administration
and is in place in over 32 states
government
issued photo id has been the global
standard for documentary identification
purposes for decades
i recently talked with a hoosier who had
dual citizenship she was an american
citizen
and she is a mexican citizen she showed
me her voting card
a specially issued card just for voting
that not only had her picture
but a copy of her thumb fingerprint
that was compared at the voting booth
when she
had to use it uh i had to dip her thumb
in ink
and use it to compare now this is mexico
by many a third world country that has
better turnout than we do
upholding the integrity of one citizen
one vote there
and here this bill making a lot less
a lot lower standard than that illegal
we're going in the opposite direction
for a free society
regardless of which party or candidate
voter favors all americans should have
confidence in the outcomes of their
elections no americans vote
should be devalued by fraudulent votes
earlier this month 19 of my attorney
general colleagues joined me in a letter
to your leadership opposing
hr1 similar to s1 as we wrote in the
letter the act has several
constitutional deficiencies and mandates
that if passed
would federalize state elections and
impose burdensome costs and regulations
on state
local officials the measures proposed in
s1 turn our constitutional election
structure
on its head they would open the door for
greater fraud
and less confidence our system of
governments depends
on the electorate having faith in the
outcome of our elections removing voter
integrity measures such as photo id laws
requiring votes to be counted up to 10
days
after the election requiring that
unaccountable commissions and dc
judges far removed from the states
should draw our district lines
isn't going to solve any of that is
going to make the situation worse
voters should have a voice through their
directly elected representatives
in their states and how these elections
should be run
while the bill pretends to apply only to
federal elections the simple fact is
these changes will apply across the
board
because no state can afford to have
separate elections for state elections
and federal ones
state should continue to hold elections
in a manner that best suits
each state and that's one would take
control entirely away
from from the states simply put if
states are laboratories and that's what
our founders intended and that's what's
been proven time and time again
the passage of s1 would make the state's
laboratories
closed and no innovation would occur
should the act become law i could tell
you the sun won't set in indiana
before we sue the federal government and
i'm sure
other states will join thank you for
your time
thank you next for our final witness
michael waldman the president of the
brennan center for justice
thank you madam chairwoman ranking
member blount
and members of the committee thank you
for the opportunity to testify on behalf
of this
landmark legislation we believe
the for the people act s1 would be the
most
significant democracy reform measure
in over half a century it is the next
great civil rights bill in response to
the demand for racial justice in our
country
it is long overdue and it is urgently
needed
now now as you know there are a number
of reforms
in this legislation relating to curbing
the role of money in politics
to dealing with gerrymandering to
dealing with ethics
i want to focus on the sacred right to
vote which is
in so many ways at the heart of our
democracy
and our understanding of ourselves as
americans
and i ask you to think about what
happened in 2020
despite the pandemic despite voter
suppression despite the lies
it was the highest voter turnout since
1900
and as has been said the trump
administration's
own department of homeland security
confirmed it was the most secure
election
ever this is something we ought to
celebrate instead
what has happened we had the big lie
about the election
being stolen we had the insurrection
driven by that big lie
and now in states across the country a
wave of
legislative attempts to curb the vote
the most significant attempted cutback
in voting rights since the jim crow era
the brennan center has studied these
laws for years
and found as has been mentioned 253
laws that would in one way or another uh
cut back on voting that was last month
seven times higher than the rate four
years ago and the number is actually
higher right now these laws are being
pushed hard
it is only march i should note and
already the governor of iowa has
signed into law significant cutbacks for
example
and vote by mail in georgia the
legislature is finishing
its work this week on an egregious bill
there was a public outcry uh that uh
that
has forced changes but there are still
tremendously harmful provisions that
will be
moving through the legislature these
laws
that we see across the country affect
voters of color
young voters poor voters and the intent
i'm afraid is often unambiguous one of
the sponsors
of these bills in arizona said the
purpose was
to make sure that only quote quality
voters
had the right to vote not that everybody
would have the right to vote
that does not strike me as true to
our american spirit s1 the for the
people act
deals with this in a very important way
and i want to be very clear
this legislation would stop this wave
of voter suppression cold it stops it
in its tracks and congress has the power
the right the authority constitutionally
and
legally to do this what this bill would
do
is set national standards to ensure that
every
eligible citizen has the freedom to vote
and the ability to make that ballot
count
it would make automatic voter
registration already the law
in 19 states democratic and republican
states
the law of the land it would ensure
access to vote by mail
and early voting and other things that
proved so popular
and so effective in recent years and are
used by tens of millions of people
enthusiastically
it would ensure the right to vote be
given to returning citizens after they
are incarcerated so they can
rejoin our society we take all these
important steps
and i note again that every one of the
things
in this legislation every proposal in
this legislation
is based on a tested and effective
reform
or policy at the national level at the
state level
and at the local level it would bolster
election security in significant ways
and has
has been noted you are more likely to be
hit by lightning than to commit voter
impersonation in the united states
we can't allow uh the conspiracy theory
about massive misconduct
to guide policy and i will note also
that this legislation in very
significant ways
honors the constitution the elections
clause gives congress this power
and i would note as well that the
supreme court
of the united states in 2019 in an
opinion by john roberts
specifically pointed to this legislation
as a constitutionally sound example of
congress's power
to set election law this is part of the
great story of american democracy
will we live up to our best ideals will
we build a multi-racial democracy that
really represents
all people will we allow a drive
to take place to turn the clock back to
cut back on those rights
this legislation would be a significant
and again long
overdue milestone for our country and i
urge you
to enact it thank you very much
mr waldman thank you to all of our
witnesses i'll begin the questioning and
then turn it over to senator blunt
um i did want to clarify one thing i've
been heard hearing the word
chaos tossed around well let me tell you
what chaos is chaos
as what we've seen in the last years
five hours five-hour six-hour lines in
states like arizona to vote chaos
is purging names of long-time voters
from a voter list so they can't go vote
in states like georgia
chaos is a state of texas declaring that
you can only have one drop-off box for
votes and ballots in their state
including huge counties like harris
county with nearly five million people
chaos is forcing people in wisconsin to
stand in garbage bags in the rain
waiting in line just to exercise their
right to vote
chaos is people in south carolina being
told that they have to have a notary
public to be able to get
a mail-in ballot and having to have it
do it through a window
of a hospital while they've got covet
chaos is a law in north carolina that a
circuit court ruled was so
discriminatory
against african americans that they said
this is a conservative circuit court
that it was designed with surgical
precision
their words not mine to discriminate
against
african americans and chaos is what we
saw happen at the capitol
when people heard for an entire year
that our election isn't sound and they
decided to come here
and take it under their own hands that
angry mob
that was chaos and what this bill tries
to do
is to simply make it easier for people
to vote and take the best practices
that what we've seen across the country
foreign
you